we have an apology to make so this is a
story a timcast IRL will be making a
formal apology to Ned Fulmer this is the
daily mail saying married Ned Fulmer is
fired from the popular YouTube show the
try guys after photos of him making out
with his engaged producer or post it
online by her fiance and as you know the
try guys produce that video that
revealed their testosterone levels were
the equivalent to an 80 year old man and
we referred to them as soy boys I would
like to formally apologize because dude
is a player he's hooking up with all
these chicks they're posting photos man
this guy's all over the place you know
so he has to be on trt absolutely on trt
absolutely there's no way you could
rebound from from that and from what was
this his T levels were that of an 80
year old absolutely but how do you
explain him having two women at the same
time trt trt yeah okay wait so so the
first one is his wife is that his wife
is that is that his wife okay yeah and
then the second one
um and that's and then Falmer was
exposed cheating with this producer
Alexandria Herring pictured with her
fiance will Thayer when the sharp-eyed
club go recorded the pair making out
I mean he's not in horrible shape and he
probably got those medical results and
any kind of uh you know legitimate
doctor would have been like hey this is
serious you got to deal with these low
testosterone numbers as of course low
testosterone is correlated with bone
density mental health physical health
and overall well-being and you can't be
well especially if you're not you know
swole and and and and happy and content
with yourself and and have the proper
if you have the proper ability to to be
able to supplicate yourself
real quick before we do that I want to
hold that thought in yeah because when
we were looking into this story and I
was like whoa this is the guy from the
testosterone thing right so BuzzFeed I'm
sorry daily wire says BuzzFeed guys test
their testosterone levels the results
are exactly what you'd expect uh video's
gone oh they took the video down maybe
because they were tired of being called
Low T soy boys but hey man dude's a
player he's looking him so my question
that's too much testosterone apparently
there's a lot of questions here Ian if
you've got a depleted testosterone
levels because of the phthalates or
whatever you've been done it to yourself
dietarily or whatever then you take trt
to replenish it are you then overly
jazzed like is it going to make you
overly aggressive like is if you're not
getting the Natural Balance and you're
trying to balance it out with X and
Dodge it like external sources well a
medical doctor will check your levels
and make sure that you are supplicating
the right amount to make sure that
you're you're going to be healthy yeah
yeah so supplementing or supplicating
potato potato you know
again I know what I'm talking about here
you got to take me seriously I have all
the membranes to uh to to to this
conversation means to ask or beg for
something earnestly or humbly yeah yeah
yeah so so the body asks humbly for the
testosterone and then the doctor humbly
gives it to them and then injects them
with it and then and then helps them
specifically humbling I guess the
question and maybe you guys don't know
the answer if say your levels are at 50
average good levels are 50 but you're at
20 naturally and you take 30 of external
back to 50 is it different than just
naturally being at 50. I don't know I'd
imagine to a certain degree because it's
not the same kind of testing that's what
I'm that's what I'm wondering is if guys
do it to get back officially you become
dependent on it for the rest of your
life Joe Rogan talks about this and
there's certain individuals that take a
lot of artificial testosterone and some
individuals who who uh you know overdose
on it and and don't dose it correctly
and then have a lot of negative
consequences for it uh that do hurt
their mental and physical state so you
know medical doctor usually uh will help
you get the right amount of swole uh to
to make sure that uh you know you're in
a very healthy physical shape just like
I am just swollen enough yeah just just
so you have the optimal physical the
optimal swole it's a little swole now
that we got the jokes out of the way I
actually want to point out cheating on
your wife is definitely a low T move
let me think about this think of the
Chad meme like the the gray picture of
the guy with the big chisel chair and
the 12-pack that Meme I don't think
would ever be applied to a guy cheating
on his wife you know what I mean like
what I mean is cheating on your wife is
viewed no and by the left and the right
as an extremely negative and wrong thing
to do and no one would ever call a
cheater a Chad you know what I mean
right like I mean I'm not saying
literally but it's just like a negative
No One's Gonna like the Chad meme is
someone who's successful and prominent
yeah somebody's calling Adam Levine a
Chad right right yeah it's just like
it's scuzzy so for this guy to be a low
T guy editing his wife in all reality
it's actually just proves the point that
he's a soy boy you know what I mean but
here's here's my my question
he got fired from the try guys
what about the producer
she's engaged no the show's over oh it
shows over apparently they're canceling
the show oh okay because it didn't it
didn't say I was reading that's so dumb
too it's like you we canceled the show
because of that we cheat on your wife
shows over everybody everyone's fired
shutting it down but there's probably
other things I mean the show is running
for a while they they might have run out
of ideas
um there could be a lot of different
things behind the scenes but again this
is personal drama we don't know the side
of the story of the man the woman the
the person who was in the relationship
there's a lot of complicated things that
that come into relationships oh no no
I'm sorry the show's not over it's what
Twitter said is the try guys announcing
they're no longer working with their
co-creator Ned Fulmer I thought I saw on
Twitter I just saw the oh okay ellipses
was like they're no longer working I
thought they were saying so he's so he
the co-creator is gone the producer who
is is also uh you know morally what's
the what's the word is it a harlot
what's the word for a woman who is like
she she's like she is the cheat e you
know what I mean there's a weird word
for this a woman charlatan succubus no
Scarlet Letter no there's like a word
for a woman who sleeps with a man who's
married uh I I don't know if I'm allowed
to say that I don't know well no because
like so so people understand on the show
people people assume these words just
mean like one thing like people think
hobo bum vagrant I mean they mean
totally different things oh totally they
literally do no no they do hobo means
Homeward Bound vagrant means like you're
Milling about aimless a bomb is somebody
who doesn't have a job and so but people
think it all means the same like a
homeless person is a hobo bum or vagrant
that's not true and so there's a word
for a woman who I don't know what it is
though I mean everyone's saying home
wrecker Jezebel oh that's a good one
yeah that's a good one yeah
mistress is the word for like what the
guy has yeah ongoing but it might be
Jezebel Mischief it might be mistress
but mistress I'm thinking oh mistress is
if a guy has like a woman on the side
other than his wife that's that mistress
that so the one will be the mistress he
wasn't married though yes he was oh he
was I thought she was married no she's
engaged she's engaged and he's married
but she still has a job right why why
does she get to stay and he he a
co-creator because he just has to leave
hey Jackie but but now he and if you
scroll down he he put out an Instagram
and he apologized he puts out an apology
saying oh well you know I should have uh
I should have I should be focusing on my
family and my kids you're like
how's it going to work because this guy
just lost like the thing that he the
biggest thing that he ever created and
you know do you think that's gonna he
doesn't have a job now you think that's
gonna actually work I don't know brand
like you think that that's gonna work
out with his family he's not gonna have
any kind of Reason how much money did he
make off the show who knows it seems
like they have like a lot of people on
their staff so yeah maybe the money
wasn't flowing as much as uh he should
in some other places if after this long
well it's been like a decade of them
doing the show if he's not set for life
with a show that big then you never know
bad money money management well I mean
he had he made bad life choices with his
that's true you know so maybe maybe uh
there's there's other things going on
that we don't know about well these are
you know personal matters and drama
right right you know it's just like yeah
I mean people you know look people in
you know in Celebrity and they cheat on
each other all the time you know someone
Super Chat us the words for the woman
Jezebel oh yes Harlot I thought
homewrecker yes that's home record that
could be a man but they said Brandon up
says I prefer slam Pig
all one word all one word Bravo that
that's that was worthless two words that
was great
is that is it what does that mean it's a
promiscuous woman typically overweight
or ugly is that the definition for
pumping and dumping end quote uh from
dictionary slam pig is the uh the yes
two words to your movie
yeah and the sequel and the sequel
assumes that you know everything about
the first gameplay
I still can't find the first one
that is a funny idea the pigs cometh two
yeah and it's just like what's the first
one yeah I love it
well no the pigs cometh again yeah
hopefully this dude works it out with
his family you know it's not the end of
the world honesty is the key and you can
get ahead of it by being honest with
your partner if you want to have sex
with somebody else then you that's a
conversation you should have before you
do it but as the as the wife do you do
you think you know that you're going to
be like oh yeah I forgive you yet I mean
I mean well that's tough question I
remember this was photos of him making
out
we don't know if anything actually
happened beyond that we don't know maybe
there was he was in distress and
couldn't breathe and it was having a
heart attack yes he's giving her mouth
to mouth to help her yeah you know again
with the way the corporate media we
don't know every we don't know all the
deals you know she was on the ground and
he's giving her mouth to mouth and the
guy turns the camera sideways to make it
seem like they're up against the wall we
know less about this than the explosions
on uh on uh North Korean Nordstrom no no
or ask it Korean Jean-Pierre would say
uh Nordstrom to Nordstroms that was that
was impressive except Nordstrom she's a
very impressive person
oh man you know this feels like the end
of an era
it's like this is it I don't think I've
ever seen a try guys episode in my life
just alone so uh the low but they got
like tens of millions of hits on these
videos it was insane like who watches
this stuff I guess people watch it I got
seven point wait hold on can we pull up
their Channel it says 7.8 million
subscribers what's their like you know
view to subscriber ratio like on a your
uh typical episode there's probably
there's probably a lot now because
people are like oh wait what's this try
guys thing about about a million they
look like they put out a video every few
days and they get you know million and a
half 1.6 this one got three we need to
talk about Texas featuring better or
work as like uh 313 000 views very low
views on that one
surprise surprise yeah this one from two
weeks ago Keith eats everything at Pizza
Hut uh-oh wow that's like horrible beats
that you're incentivizing the chai try
try the try guys ruin chocolate eclairs
try guys try colonics
I wonder what that was like oh geez I
see why people watch this that's
probably monetized family friendly show
yeah
this is like a TV show it's 20 minutes
long one's an hour long it's like fully
produced how many ad breaks do you think
they have I probably get the premium ads
too they probably get like all the good
stuff women get mammograms for them
getting like solar panel stuff I wonder
what their like biggest video is most
popular the try guys get their bones
cracked oh man can you teach everything
a Panera got a ton of views so the Keith
eats everything there there's a
chiropractor uh channel that needs one
and my back yeah you know it's like
every month Keith does a new look at
this look at this one look at this one I
like Keith Keith everything at KFC and
it like what's with his face it's part
of a series dude this guy beats
everything at Panera Bread is that what
time Eugene joined him at Taco Bell's
like I'm in on that virgin Eugene what
oh wow wow this is oh look man I think
if they make a show people like it you
know good for them that's fine versus
high that's pretty okay hey chat chat do
you guys like regularly watch the try
guys let us know let us know in the chat
please press one if you have to press
two if no here's here's the thing about
it it's like we're saying X for doubt
we're sitting here going like uh who
watches this stuff and they get like
substantially more views than we do yeah
Keith eats everything they actually like
Red Lobster yeah four million views wait
where what really that's six months ago
are you kidding no no 3.9 defeats
everything at Olive Garden he's just
just taken advantage who is this magic
man named Keith how many years are you
gonna keep doing this brother
Carl's Jr
probably living out of childhood fantasy
yeah but the truth is you really can't
because a lot of the food there is just
mix and match of other Foods so it's
like is he eating like a bowl of parsley
and then eating a noodle and then eating
a piece of chicken ORS because you can
order like 50 different noodle dishes
which are just combinations you know
what I mean the series finale is Keith
eats everything at a grocery store Keith
regurgitates everything he ate in the
last year everyone in the chat room is
is typing in two majority okay look I
know you're shocked to be fair the try
guys get comparable views to just this
show alone but in terms of like the Tim
cast chose they get substantially less
well look I mean they have seven they
have 7.8 million subs and they're
getting
they're they're getting 28 million to
watch a guy eat so I mean that's pretty
good
no 2.8 2.8 million how are they gonna do
the show without Ned they're done I
don't know it's over that is kind of
demoralizing yeah thanks for checking
out this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there